today on the matt walsh show the body
cam footage of dante wright's death
has been released today we're going to
have the uncomfortable conversation
about that footage and about wright's
death
that the media refuses to have also five
headlines including some bizarre and
chilling
footage from the press conference with
the brooklyn center police chief the
media on camera tries to convince him in
real time
that the rioting he just experienced was
not actually rioting it didn't really
happen
also the white house unveils its
strategy to convince white conservatives
to get vaccinated it's as cartoonish and
insulting as you might expect and our
daily cancellation will cancel the actor
who
formerly voiced the character of pooh on
simpsons and who now says that he wants
to apologize to each indian person
individually
for that character you know that's
getting them canceled we'll talk about
that and much more today on the matt
walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if we want to take back the culture then
that's going to start first and foremost
one of the one of one of the primary
things we can do is support the
companies
that have morals that we agree with and
that are supporting us as well
in the culture one company that fits
that description is charity mobile the
pro-life phone company
and uh we call the pro-life phone
company because five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice
we know that the right to life is the
key that unlocks the other rights it's
the it's the
right that lays the foundation of all of
the rights we don't have the right to
life you don't have anything else
and and that's why we should support all
pro-life phone companies especially a
great company like charity mobile which
also
on top of it provides a great service
now through april 16th new activations
get a free cell phone after instant
credit plus free activation free
shipping and a free pro-life
key chain credit check required
restrictions apply on that you also get
look there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's no risk with a
30-day guarantee
which means there's no reason to not at
least try out charity mobile and see how
you like the servers i guarantee you're
going to love it
you can help to build a culture of life
in america while supporting a pro-life
phone company
so get the the the the provider that i
use charity mobile
call them at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them online at charitymobile.com
rioting continued in minneapolis last
night as looters anarchists and other
assorted scumbags took advantage
of the implicit permission they've been
given to steal and destroy at will we
know this is the way it works now if
there's a
police shooting well only a police
shooting of a black person of course as
we discussed yesterday
police shooting of a white person we're
not supposed to care about that but
police police shooting of a black person
what that means is that you're allowed
to just go out and destroy things that's
that's the precedent we've set now
one store that got hit especially hard
was a dollar tree
in downtown minneapolis the store was
ransacked
vandalized and then set on fire
now let's watch some brief footage of
the aftermath
and even more importantly i want you to
listen to this clip let's listen
[Music]
all right you uh you hear that it sounds
like
people laughing and joking around after
they just randomly destroyed a local
business for no reason
the media tells us that the people who
did this are emotionally distraught
angry striving in their own unique way
for racial justice
from the look and sound of it it seems
to me that these people just thought
it'd be kind of fun to steal and burn
some stuff
that's it now all kinds of jokes could
be made here about the whole idea of
looting a dollar tree of all places
i mean a store that already practically
gives its items away for free
and you loot there but there really
isn't anything funny about it the fact
is that low-income people in that city
rely
on the dollar tree in places like dollar
tree for household
goods and groceries the quote protesters
decided to speak out against police
brutality by once again
victimizing members of their own
community
and and they are protesters again of
course just just so we know after a
brief detour on january 6 2021
we're back now to calling rioters
protesters and using euphemisms like
unrest
to describe the mass destruction of
property so make sure to update your
language guides accordingly
meanwhile the police on monday afternoon
before the second round of rioting
kicked off
released the body cam footage of the
attempted arrest and then shooting of
dante wright
initial reports were that wright was
pulled over for having an air freshener
in his car this was immediately
translated through the demented
translation engine known as twitter into
dante wright having been shot by police
for having an air freshener as expected
none of this is anywhere within the
vicinity of the ballpark of the truth
not true at all right was stopped for an
expired registration
not an unusual thing to be stopped for i
myself have been stopped for the same
reason
on more than one occasion mostly because
i have a deep phobia of
sitting in the dmv and i'll put it off
for as long as possible basically until
they
pull me over and give me a fine that's
when i know that it's time to do it
in wright's case the cops upon stopping
him
found out that there was a warrant for
his arrest he was wanted on a weapons
charge and had skipped his court date
wright had a rap sheet extending beyond
even that including an arrest for
aggravated robbery a few months prior
the brooklyn center police chief said
that wright
was shot accidentally after he resisted
arrest
and climb back into his car to try and
escape one of the arresting officers a
female
pulled her gun when she meant to go for
her taser
now the body cam footage seems to fully
support the claim that it was accidental
let's um and this is disturbing
obviously so i'll give you that warning
but let's watch it now
okay so the main reason i want to play
that because if you're listening to the
audio you couldn't see what happened
there but uh he
they were resting right he and he broke
free tried to get into his car
um but it's what you hear her say at the
end it's obvious from her reaction
that she didn't mean to shoot him you
know now that's no excuse of course and
it wouldn't get her out of and and i
suspect will not get her out of the
criminal charges that
are probably coming any officer that
can't tell the difference between a
taser and a gun shouldn't be on the
force
that's uncontroversial i think we all
agree nearly everyone's on the same page
on that score
and there is i would guess near
universal agreement that she should not
have made the mistakes she made
everyone agrees she'll now be held
accountable for that mistake
if we were interested in making actually
useful reforms to the police however
what we talk about now is how a female
police officer
who obviously can't physically subdue
suspects and also isn't competent with
her service weapon
managed to remain on the force for we're
told now 26 years
there's quite a lot of talk about police
reform but this is reform
the reform we really need and it's it's
the one that we don't talk about
it is a hazard to have cops on the force
who can be easily overpowered by almost
any male suspect that they come across
and that's going to put them in a
position either where suspects get away
or where they have to resort to a taser
or a gun where more where a more
physically well-matched police officer
may not have needed to use either
but again the police reformers on the
left they don't want to have that
conversation
i mean a female police officer is 26
years old on a force
this now is a middle-aged woman she's
not going to be physically subduing
anyone and obviously not competent with
her with her service weapon
26 years she made it
but like i said we don't want to talk
about that even less do we want to talk
about and have the conversation about
dante wright's behavior
now i realize that by saying what i'm
about to say i put myself in line for
all kinds of angry accusations that i'm
a heartless victim-blaming sob and so
forth
but the truth is that i actually don't
want people to die
talk about an uncontroversial view what
should be uncontroversial
i don't want people to die i don't want
people to be shot by the cops
i don't want cops to end up in the
position that this female officer is now
in
i don't want any of this it's all bad
everything about this
is bad i don't want any of it and anyone
who feels this way who actually wants to
preserve human life
along with peace and law and order while
we're at it would acknowledge
the following reality which is this
if dante wright had not resisted arrest
he would be alive today period
he was wanted on a valid warrant okay
this wasn't some ticky tack
thing this this was not him getting shot
in the process of
a traffic stop no he was found in
possession of a firearm
that's what the warrant was about that
according to minnesota's minnesota state
law he was too young to possess
also he has a history of drug and
robbery arrests which would probably
make him ineligible for a permit i
imagine
what this all means is that he broke the
law and the police have a right and
responsibility to bring him in
they were doing so peacefully without a
problem okay
until wright pushed the officer away and
tried to speed away in his car planning
i suppose
to lead the officers on a high speed
chase with a passenger
in the vehicle with him this was a very
bad plan
it is a plan with literally no possible
positive
outcome if you're wanted on a warrant
and then you run from the cops absolute
best case scenario
is that you end up getting apprehended a
little bit later and now you have a
whole slew of new charges on top of the
original one
you buy yourself maybe a few minutes of
extra freedom in exchange you get a few
years
extra in prison so
best case scenario when you do what
dante wright did there
is you go to prison for longer that's
best case
worst case is what happened to dante
wright
there is no plausible scenario where
wright runs away and actually evades the
police successfully
and then lives happily ever after that's
not going to happen
it's either prison or the hospital or
the morgue
the moment that dante wright pushed the
police officers away
and got back in his car he made a
decision
that was absolutely guaranteed to lead
to the hospital the prison or the morgue
no other possible options the only
outcomes
when you do what right did which means
that if we want young men like right to
avoid prisons and avoid the hospitals
and avoid the morgues and i do
then our message should be don't do that
am i saying that right is partially
responsible for his own death
yes of course he is he made a choice a
bad choice any legal choice
that set off a series of events which
resulted in his death
does that absolve the police officer no
you know
two people can be responsible for an
event that happens that
that is quite often the case so she is
also responsible
there's lots of responsibility to go
around but when you absolve
rights and people like right when you
absolve him completely
all you're doing is encouraging more
dante rights
which means more death and more
suffering
and more mother's mourning you are not
the compassionate one in that case
you may get to play the compassionate
one on the internet or out in the
streets when you're protesting quote
unquote
but in truth you are a callous and a
moral person because you don't really
care
you would rather stand on dante wright's
grave and posture
that actually do and say things that
might discourage the next young man
from making the same self-destructive
choice
but we're all expected to play this game
right the media tells us that dante
wright was shot during a traffic stop as
if there is no difference at all between
a man who gets shot in the head executed
simply for going 12 miles over the limit
like he's speeding the cops walk over
and just shoot him dead
and say that's what you get for speeding
you know they want to they want us to to
pretend that there's no difference
between that
and a wanted fugitive who pushes the
police away and tries to speed off in
his car
when they're arresting him we're
supposed to see the latter scenario as
identical to the former when we know
that they are not
identical this is just another
common sense insight that many people
are hectored into pretending that they
don't see or understand
and as we refuse either due to cowardice
or ideological commitments or whatever
else
to acknowledge the very clear role that
the george floyd's and dante rights of
the world play in their own demises
more and more suffer that same demise
their lives don't actually matter to the
people who do most of the screaming
about how their lives matter
they're just props chess pieces to be
moved around on the board
while we all ignore the simple truths
that are staring us right in the face
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from our friends at
rock auto listen nobody likes to
spend their time waste their time
traipsing around at auto parts store
looking for the the item that you want
what you're going to find is it's
oftentimes not a great selection and one
thing you can be sure of
is that the prices are you know going to
be more than you need to be paying or
you should be paying
especially when you could just pull out
your phone which you have on you at all
times i imagine and go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible they're not going to
change the prices
whether you're professional do it
yourself or whatever wherever you land
on that spectrum
uh it's gonna be the same price for
everybody rockauto.com is a family
business they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low if you
find it on rockauto.com you can be sure
that whatever the price is there you're
not going to find it
a better price anywhere else so go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car
truck and remember as always when you go
there to write walsh in their how did
you hear about his box
so they know that we sent you all right
you know i've been going through a
tough time at home there was
i had a difficult moment with my
daughter
few last week we were sitting down at
the couch
it's kind of a kind of a parenting scary
because we were sitting down on the
couch
and uh she turns me out of the blue and
she tells me my seven-year-old daughter
she tells me she wants to be a
vegetarian
and now the and she didn't know the word
actually at first she said that she said
daddy what's that
when someone only eats vegetables and i
said vegetarian
and she said yeah i'm that that's what i
want to be
of course i'm thinking to myself no
daughter of mine no daughter of mine
is going to be a vegetarian but you know
i realized there were there were signs
leading up to this like
for example earlier last summer we were
out
i was out fishing with her and she
caught like it was like a bluegill or
something
and uh she pulled the hook out and i
guess caused some internal bleeding it
happened
threw the fish back in catch and release
and the fish bob back up to the surface
and was just laying there
right and then she pointed to the fish
and said daddy why is the fish laying
there i said oh he's probably uh
probably sleeping
you know took a lot out of him when you
caught him
and then it started bleeding and she
said wha but why what's the redstone why
is it bleeding
and then i had to admit well he's yeah
you might have killed him it's okay
though don't worry
she was devastated by that absolutely
devastated i think that was the
beginning of her animal rights activism
but anyway fast forward she tells me
she's a vegetarian
and i'm pretty distraught over that
because i can't imagine having a
vegetarian in the house
but the next day i'm talking to her
again and she tells me that uh she
decided
that she's a vegetarian but she can
still eat chicken nuggets so she'll make
an exception for that
then the day after that she said that
well i'm a vegetarian but i eat chicken
nuggets but also
of course like sausage and bacon with
breakfast i can have that
and then each each successive day she
started adding more
meat products onto her vegetarian diet
until now she's just packed
she's a vegetarian who also eats meat
which is fine which is perfectly valid
that is a self-identity that i can
respect
uh and and her trajectory of
vegetarianism i think follows a similar
trajectory of a lot of people who you
know announced themselves to be
vegetarian
all right um so number one the governor
of
minnesota yesterday gave a press
conference
talking about the dante wright case and
um let's listen we'll just we'll listen
in quickly to see what he has to say
about this
nothing terribly interesting it's a lot
of what you would expect
but to me the highlight is more what he
doesn't say
during the press conference so let's
take a listen and so some of the things
that we can do
and and we need to be very clear about
is
this state this community and this
nation needs to have a place to grieve
and to express in many places
their anger that this continues to go on
and their expectation that things need
to be different
and need to change and so our commitment
of making sure
that those that are exercising their
first amendment rights and those that
are
asking no demanding that changes
changes that are happening in other
states like maryland we saw last week
changes that are making a difference
changes that are reducing
the chance of these types of things
happening
we need to make sure that that space is
available and we also though need to
hold at the same time
that those that wish to do harm or
destruction to property
or to put people at risk it will not be
tolerated
and we have known for many months that
as this trial
and the focus of this nation was on this
trial
that there would be those that want to
do both those that want to bring about
change those that want to express
their constitutional rights those that
are angry
heartbroken sad fed up tired all of the
things that they have
every reason to feel but we also know
and we saw it again last night
those that would try and take advantage
of this to create chaos or damage
will not be tolerated heartbroken i'm so
heartbroken i have to steal these shoes
i'm just so high and so distraught
i had what could i do but take these
shoes it's my only solace
right he says it's not gonna be
tolerated he said that and then that
night
they went and burned down a a dollar
tree and
well first they stole all the stuff out
of the dollar tree and then they burned
it down
and uh we played the video for you there
people are just milling around
casually laughing having a great time
but that's see when he says we're not
gonna tolerate the destruction
that's what he means what he means is
we're we will tolerate it actually you
could do whatever you want
we will uh maybe we'll send you a
sternly worded
letter condemning it
i'm not even really condemning it
because that's a little bit strong but
asking if you would consider maybe not
burning down buildings in the future
but the real and he went on in in the
press conference
as i said the real headline is what he
didn't say
and here's one thing that he didn't say
what he didn't say was this shooting
had nothing to do with racism which it
didn't
clearly there is absolutely no reason to
think that this had anything to do with
racism
they were arresting the guy because he
had an outstanding warrant what else are
the cops going to do when you have an
outstanding warrant
and um and then the shooting occurred
when he started to resist arrest and the
and the the cop pulled the wrong weapon
now
if you're if you're suggesting that race
where does race come into play here
there is no connection to racism
whatsoever not only has the governor
not said that but he's implied the
opposite in fact
right after the event happened that
night he sent out a tweet saying
this is on sunday night i'm closely
monitoring the situation in brooklyn
center gwen and i
are praying for dante wright's family as
our state mourns another life of a black
man
taken by law enforcement
clearly implying there's a connection to
racism here another life of a black man
taken by law enforcement
he included the race there for a reason
to imply that this is race related
and all through the press conference
that's what he's doing
once again if you really cared about
preserving human life
and um and certainly if you cared about
law and order then you would get up
there
in front of your people and you would
say as the leader as the governor you
would say
this had this was a terrible thing it
had nothing to do with racism
whatsoever you know the officer will be
held accountable
for the mistake that she made which was
terrible had nothing to do with racism
dante wright was not killed because he's
a black man
in fact of all of the police shootings
that blm
has protested and by protesters we mean
burn burn and destroy uh other people's
property
but of all those police shootings not a
single
one has had any confirmed link or even
plausible
theoretical link to racism
not a single one they have been wrong
about the racism link
every single time year after year
after year incident after incident they
are wrong about that every single time
and usually they're wrong about almost
everything else they say about the case
also
now the police chief um i wanted to play
this for you too he's he's uh
giving his own briefing to the media and
here he is
um talking about the rioting
and having the the people in the media
the press try to convince him to his
face
that he didn't actually experience the
rioting that he personally experienced
let's listen
what what led to you to issue a
dispersal order and then on the back end
of that 10-minute dispersal order
then to issue out uh co2 canisters and
gas
for the crowd yeah just so everybody's
clear i was
fronting front and center at the protest
at the
at the riot um
so i was we were being the officers
that were putting themselves in harm's
way were being pelted with frozen cans
a pop they were being belted with
concrete blocks
and yes we had our helmets on and we had
other protection gear but
an officer was injured hit in the head
with a brick that was a hennepin county
deputy
he was transported to the hospital so we
had to make decisions we had to disperse
the crowd because we can allow
our officers to be harmed and i've
already answered the question i believe
about your lighting
i know that's a that's a big deal with
you and i understand that but i thought
i'd explain that myself so that is
i told you it's my decision and that's
why i made that decision
there was no writing you could almost
imagine them like a cartoon they've got
the pocket watch out
and they're hypnotizing him and they're
hoping that he has little you know
squirrels swirls in his eyes there was
no rioting
there was no rioting um
no there was he he was just there his
officers were hit in the head with
bricks
there were buildings burned down we just
saw the footage of looting that's going
on i mean
it it it feels fruitless and pointless
to even
point out when the media is lying but
what else are we gonna do but point it
out you know let him do it and and
and not even make the observation
but the lying here is so brazen
i i hate to keep using the term
orwellian it's so overused but it but it
in this case
i i there's no other term that applies
as well as that term does
where they are lying to you about what
you are seeing with your own eyes and
telling you that you're not seeing
what you're seeing
there was no rioting it's it's not even
like they won't even do us the favor
they're insulting our intelligence so
much that they think they can
tell us that there was no writing at all
rather than
a slightly more plausible lie or you
know
taking the approach of saying yeah there
was writing but it's justified for this
and that reason
that is also insane and stupid and wrong
but at least you're acknowledging
some of the reality in that case now as
it happens from the left we actually get
both of those things
on one hand they tell us that there's no
writing on the other hand they tell us
that
uh well if there is writing it it's
justified it it's not it doesn't exist
but if it does exist then it's here's
why it's justified
trying to play play both ends of it
there all right um
this is a report from what is this from
nbc and uh
i'll read a little bit it's a long
report
it says in semi-private encrypted chats
neo-nazis and other far-right extremists
planned
planned rallies and dozens of cities on
sunday to promote their racist movements
and spread their ideologies to larger
audiences hyped by organizers as events
that would make
the whole the whole world tremble the
rallies ran into a major problem
hardly anyone showed up so this was this
past sunday
the quote white lives matter rallies the
first major
real world organizing efforts by white
supremacists since 2018
were planned on the encrypted app
telegram after many aligned groups were
alleged to have taken place
taking part in the in the january 6
storming of the us capital
the poor showing underscores how the
country's unpopular and disorganized
extremist movements
have been driven underground by
increased scrutiny from the media law
enforcement agencies and far left
activists who
infiltrate their private online spaces
and disrupt their
attempts to communicate and organize
okay so
and it goes on it goes on forever after
that but the point is this is nbc
spiking the football because there was
supposed
quote-unquote white supremacist rallies
that were that were going to happen on
wednes on
sunday now i don't know anything about
these rallies at all
i never heard of them like like anyone
else like the first you hear about it is
from the media
so i don't know who was involved in
organizing it
no clue um
and this you really can't do this but
taking their word for it
that there actually were quote unquote
white supremacist rallies being planned
in the first place
let's just assume we can believe the
media which i don't believe anything
they say
but then even by their own
admission here what they're telling us
is that
the white supremacists can't even get
hardly anyone to show up for a rally
okay and yet at the same time
they want us to believe that white
supremacy
is the number one threat we face as a
society
once again trying to have it both ways
there's no writing but the writing is
justified and here
uh look at these look at these crazy
white supremacists uh
the the they can't even get anyone out
to their rallies also they're a major
threat and um
and it's the number one problem we face
in society like which is it
are these a bunch of fringe wacko
morons who can't even organize a rally
or should we be living in fear of these
people because
white supremacy uh infiltrates every
aspect and
every institution of our society
it seems to me that it sort of has to be
one or the other doesn't it
now as it happens i think the way that
it's presented in this particular nbc
article
nbc news article is is much closer to
the truth
white supremacy is not a real problem in
the united states
the number of actual professed white
supremacists
this is another reason we have to be
careful because we also know that the
media
they call everything white supremacy and
they also think that any conservative
is white supremacist so when they say a
white supremacist group was planning a
rally
i don't know what they mean i don't know
if they mean just a normal conservative
group or
actual white supremacist i have no idea
but when it comes to actual white
supremacists
the numbers are so low and it is so
fringe
that uh it's not an issue
it's not something we really have to
worry about this is not a real problem
in society
the the the white supremacy has become
and we get this even from this
particular nbc news article
it's become the most delusional moral
panic
that our society has seen
in probably modern american history
the left is going around everywhere they
think they see white supremacy around
every corner
there are white supremacists lurking
everywhere meanwhile
there's like 10 of them
and they can't even show up for a rally
no racial supremacy in america is a
problem
but it's not white supremacy
that's not the kind of racial supremacy
that's gone mainstream
and that's not the kind of racial
supremacist movement that can attract
thousands of people
out into pretty much any american city
[Music]
and those are not the kinds of racial
supremacists that are burning down
buildings across the country
um let's see if you're if you're
you know if you're out there right now
think about getting back to life eating
and drinking in public again and all
that dr
fauci wants you to know that he does not
approve you must
cease and desist immediately with your
eating
and your speaking and other kinds of
revelry and frivolity you have to stop
that immediately he does not approve
here he is explaining why what is your
message tonight
to both vaccinated and unvaccinated
americans
as to what they should and should not be
doing right now for example
eating and drinking indoors in
restaurants and bars
is that okay now
no it's still not okay for the simple
reason that the level of infection the
dynamics of infection
in the community are still really
disturbingly
high like just yesterday there were
close to
000 new infections and we've been
hanging around
60 70 75 000 so
if you're not vaccinated please get
vaccinated as soon as vaccine becomes
available to you
and if you are vaccinated please
remember
that you still have to be careful and
not get involved in
crowded situations particularly indoors
where people are not wearing masks
and for the time being until we show
definitively that a person who's
vaccinated
does not get the subclinical infection
and can spread to others
you should also continue to wear a mask
for the time being
okay so once again you can't you can't
do that
you can do it but it's not going to have
the effect you're hoping when you say
to all americans please get vaccinated
and by the way when you do get
vaccinated stay locked in your home
and uh live in fear of crowded spaces
and don't go out to eat and don't live
your normal life
because the rest of that sentence you
know it negate the the
the uh the end of that sentence negates
the first part of it
the only the only vaccination message
and we'll get to here in a second
uh the biden administration and what
their how they're going about convincing
people to get vaccinated especially
conservatives
we'll play that in a second but i can
tell you
the only message that will really
convince
people to run out and get vaccinated is
is if you're saying get vaccinated and
get back to your normal life
and not get vaccinated or we won't allow
you to get back to
your normal life because when you add
that compulsion into it
that's going to backfire and it should
no if you're speaking look if you're
dealing with people who just really
aren't that worried about the
chronovirus then they're probably not
going to be vaccinated there's nothing
you can say there
but if you're if we're talking about a a
segment of the population
that has been concerned about the
coronavirus
yet they're hesitant about the vaccine
and you want them to get vaccinated and
the message to them is give vaccinated
get back to normal life
you know then get back get vaccinated
and now you don't have to be concerned
anymore and you can get back to normal
life
not because we're forcing it but just
because now you don't have to have those
concerns
as i've said many times i my opinion
on whether or not people should get
vaccinated is i don't have an opinion
the decision you have to make on your
own i don't i don't when i look at some
other person i don't have an opinion
about what shots they should go out go
to the doctor and get
entirely their choice but if you're in
the camp of we want to convince people
you vaccinated then this is the only
message
certainly it cannot be the message that
we get from jen saki in the white house
let's listen
we're also investing 3 billion dollars
to states and community-based
organizations to strengthen vaccine
confidence in the highest risk and
hardest hit
communities and often people think of
that as just black and brown communities
and that is not as you've noted that is
also
conservative communities white
evangelicals it's a range of communities
around the country
what we found to be most effective is to
work with these local organizations so
faith-based organizations community
health organizations
civic leaders and others who can really
get this message deeply
in communities we've also had a number
of our
members of our covid team from dr fauci
and
uh fr and dr collins uh participate as
an example
participate in a range of media
interviews you know an example is dr
collins participated in the 700 club
dr nunez smith hosted a faith leaders
roundtable
we're also looking for we've run psas on
the deadliest catch
we're engaged with nascar and country
music tv we're looking for a range of
creative ways to
get directly connected to white
conservative communities we won't always
be the best
messengers but we're still trying to
meet people where they are but also
empower local organizations
we're engaged with nascar country music
tv the deadliest catch
well hot dog i see that there psa on the
country music television
guess i'm gonna go get me a vaccination
that's that's what they imagine as
conservatives that's what they imagine
we're we're doing
we're just waiting for a country music
star to tell us
now we'll go get that vaccination now
how about
instead of treating people like morons
speak to them like adults
and have the message i just said before
get the vaccination get back to your
normal life
though as i said that's going to be
difficult for someone like me because
i've been living my my normal life this
entire time but
for those who haven't that might be the
best way to approach it okay
let's go to reading the youtube comments
this is from jay moran
he says uh i'm uncomfortable with the
fact that every time there's an officer
involved shooting
the public just casually accepts that a
riot will follow
the world is laughing at us this this
yes this is one of the many intolerable
unacceptable things
that we are being told we have to just
tolerate and accept i agree with you
there
um william harper says same situation
matt describes here with the police
happened to me about
21 years ago a cop got behind me and
turned on his lights we were on an
overpass so i slowed down and waited
till we were off the overpass to stop
about a third to a half of a mile
he ordered me out of a car handcuffed me
took me in and charged me with felony
fleeing
with ten thousand dollar bond one and a
half year later one and a half years
later
two lawyers 30 hours of community
service and 1500
the charges were dropped cops can be
jerks and can make your life difficult
for doing very little wrong sometimes
yeah well that's
i i said yesterday i had a i had a
situation like that where i waited too
long to pull over
uh because i thought it was the right
thing to do i learned that it wasn't
but my experience was i got the speeding
ticket and i went about my day
you had a much worse experience
but all this goes to show right that
yeah there are cops out there that are
jerks no question about it
there are also cops out there that will
try to violate your rights there's also
no doubt about that
but i'm sure you would agree william
that if you had
tried to fight this injustice
by punching the police officer then your
problems would have been a hell of a lot
worse
instead you fought it in court which is
the right place to fight it
and it it's it's annoying it's worse
than annoying
you got to spend a lot of money it's
probably rather than annoying it's
infuriating
but you're in a situation now that you
don't want to be in nothing you could do
about that
now you have to think what's the best
way of getting out of this situation
100 of the time the best way is through
the court system
that's that is the best of all of the
not great options right and sometimes in
life we are faced with a
with uh you know there's a fork in the
road and neither option is great
but one is a lot worse than the other
shanxi says a much better argument i
make as a mexican american all the time
mexican americans are killed by cops at
the same rate
why are they now why are they are there
now brown lives matter riots because we
know they probably were doing something
stupid
and got themselves shot and we believe
in family and hard work
case closed well i think
you know mexican-american that's always
an interesting category
uh racially because from the media's
perspective
and the left whether or not you get
included
you know as white or as a person of
color
it really depends on your usefulness to
the left's agenda that's kind of how
that works
um and uh
william says our culture has lost a
healthy sense of shame for shameful
conduct
yeah this is absolutely one of the major
problems that we face
that there are a lot of people in this
country who
through conditioning they simply don't
feel the kind of shame that they should
feel when they do shameful things
and that's why they'll you know you go
in
loot a dollar store what you're on
camera the whole time
waving to the camera not only should you
be worried about prosecution well i
guess maybe you shouldn't be worried
about that in minneapolis because
they're not gonna prosecute you but
at the least you should feel ashamed of
this this is a shameful embarrassing
thing
you're you're taking advantage of the
death of a young man
to steal from a dollar tree where poor
people go to buy their groceries aren't
you ashamed of that
no not capable of shame and finally
another comment says the experts say
matt walsh has the best bot podcast of
all time
i also happen to be the experts well
thank you for that and this is why i
always say
or have not always said but will now say
in this one case
trust the experts i've been telling you
about my friends over at
constitutioncoach.com for the last
several weeks and you've only got a few
more days really to get signed up for
their next class and you're going to
want to do that because
constitutioncoach.com they have a lot of
great
programs for equipping citizens to
defend liberty by studying and living
out the constitution
it's one thing to just carry a gun
around but if you're gonna
own a gun or carry on whatever whatever
the case may be um
you need to learn how to use you need to
learn about that gun that's uh
our responsibility that's what we all
should be doing with constitution coach
with the constitutional defense course
you get an amazing combination of
intellectual ammunition in live classes
with rick green america's constitution
coach and then you also get the physical
training
at the premier firearms training
facility in the nation the physical
training is really important i've done
it myself
took me to a whole new skill level but
the intellectual training is just as
important and also important
is the um the fellowship that you get
with like-minded people when you're at
these classes
don't just get a gun learn how to carry
with confidence and get the training
that you need to defend your family go
to constitutioncoach.com
rick and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th
it's filling up fast though so go now
don't waste another second go to
constitutioncoach.com
well it's already episode five and we
can't get enough of candice owens or her
new show candice if you haven't checked
it out yet
i don't know what you're waiting for the
fearless thought leader hosts a lively
uh panel every week with with
interesting guests
interviews her signature cancel corner
it's a lot of fun the show streams on
fridays 9 p.m eastern 8 pm
central at dailywire.com but you can
also get the audio podcast
candice on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcast so if you need
some candice owens in your podcast feed
make sure to go and
let's get to our daily download
today we're going to cancel hank azaria
he's an actor best known for his work on
the simpsons a show which
stopped being funny in 1998 i'd say but
has lingered on since then wandering
through the hillside way past its
expiration date half dead
flesh rotting slowly decomposing like a
zombie or
you know joe biden now azaria's most
beloved character was that of a poo
the indian american owner of kwik-e-mart
in the show this character caused really
no controversy
for about 25 years there's no reason why
it should have caused controversy yes
the character was a stereotype but then
every character on the simpsons is a
stereotype that's where the majority of
the humor comes from on the show or came
from at least
back when the show had humor as
stereotypes go
it was not a particularly negative one
apu is hard working lovable charming
he wasn't a dumb oaf like homer the
stereotype of a white suburban dad he
wasn't a miserly decrepit old coot like
mr burns the stereotype of a rich white
geezer
he was a one of the more positive and
flattering characters on the show
and that's how he was viewed by most
people until a few years ago when we
decided that it was offensive or more
precisely when i say we decided
one guy decided that it was offensive
and made a whole documentary called
the problem with a poo explaining why it
offended him
now the appropriate response when
someone makes a documentary
to complain about a cartoon character
that offended him is some mixture of
confused glaring and derisive laughter
but the simpsons reaction eventually was
to apologize and to get rid of the
character entirely
and that brings us to hank azaria who
eventually stepped down from the role
and has been on apology tour
to make amends ever since he desperately
wants people to forgive him
for playing this character reason
recently he appeared on a podcast called
armchair expert hosted by dak shepard
and uh someone named mona the
conversation inevitably turned to the
apu controversy and the discussion
discussion became perhaps
perhaps the most cancelable thing that i
have ever canceled on this show
this conversation that you're about to
hear snippets of
is excruciating but also instructive
so we have to endure it together we'll
get through this together
at least at least part of it so first i
want you to hear how
dax the host sets up the conversation i
want you to listen to this
okay so one thing we have to talk about
which i don't think you'll be afraid to
talk about at all but
people who listen to the show obviously
probably be aware of this and obviously
monica is also indian so this is a great
person to be involved in this
conversation
what i know of your response based on
the movie there was a movie right the
problem with apu
yes which was a documentary film calling
out the character of apu
and my voicing of it yeah and
man you want to talk about if it were me
the temptation i would have
to defend myself because i would feel
like someone was calling me
personally a racist and my identity
would be on the line like i'll fight to
the death
to prove to you i'm not a racist the
fact that your response was such that
the maker of the film
publicly thanked you for how you
responded to it
again to bring it all back to aaa i mean
it has to be in the mix right like can
you make
that response without the work you've
done listen to the language there
i would fight to the death to prove i'm
not a racist
and he would this stands in contrast to
my own approach as someone who won't
even like
fight you in a thumb war to prove i'm
not a racist i won't i literally won't
lift a finger to prove i'm not racist i
won't do a single thing at all to prove
i'm not a racist
and that's because i'm not a monkey with
a tambourine marching around and making
noises at your best
i'm not a a puppet dancing on your
string i'm not a dog
barking like a man whatever analogy you
prefer it's not my job
to prove anything to you and i don't
care to
i'm not going to be held hostage by the
bogus labels you throw at me
and considering the fact that all white
people are called racists for literally
everything we do and say
all the time the term has lost all
meaning and power
i don't care when people try to pin it
on me it doesn't mean anything
it has no impact and this is how you
really neutralize
the labeling tactic if somebody says
you're racist and you break down in
tears like dax here begging them
screaming
no i'm not i swear i'm not pleased
believe me i'm not
they already win and you already lose
the whole point of them calling you that
was to get exactly that reaction
which is why it frustrates them so much
when they say you're racist
and you respond with a yawn and say oh
you think so
okay well you're not going to deny it
that they don't know what to do with
that
you're not following the script and you
shouldn't
but dax does there are a lot of people
like dax out there many of them named
dax
as it happens people whose identities
are so tied up in
and dependent upon approval from
mainstream society that they can't bear
losing it
to lose that approval would be an act of
suicide in their minds
you know to to accept the fact that
people are calling you racist to them to
someone like dax
that is like committing suicide it would
be to lose everything that gives their
lives meaning and value
this makes them very easy to control and
manipulate
and you hear that through the rest of
this interview these two grown men
you know using the language of of 19
year old blue haired feminist dance
theory majors
that's what they sound like and and and
groveling constantly to the woman on the
show mona who is apparently indian
let's listen to some of that if we can
stomach it here they are groveling and
proving again how
not racist they are uh in in their
discussion with uh with
the indian uh woman on the show let's
listen congratulating me for the
response
because i had a big part in creating the
problem to begin with
so nothing takes that away except maybe
in amends over time which i'm attempting
to make but
and i'm interested to hear monica i'd
love to i don't put you on the spot in
order to put you in the position of
a person of color having to like uh talk
about any of this be the mouth
piece yeah may not want to but well this
goes perfect she'll be consoling us by
the end of this which is
the greatest pleasures a marginalized
person can have
i'm hoping to bring up take a side back
door into white fragility and you take
care of me
listening to that i was half expecting
both of these guys
to strip off their shirts fall to their
knees and start doing this
[Music]
more
[Laughter]
[Music]
lives matter black lives matter
[Music]
apparently he thinks black lives matter
i don't know if you picked up on that
if virtue signaling ever becomes an
olympic sport we will have some of the
best competitors on the globe no doubt i
could say that much
at least speaking of virtue signaling
hank azaria
went on to explain how he came to the
conclusion that the cartoon character he
voiced was racist this involved among
other things
attending seminars listen so i needed to
educate myself
a lot because on the one hand i didn't
want a knee jerk respond to like what
could have been
i'm like is this 17 hipsters in a micro
brewery in brooklyn just deciding
or is this like a real thing it's just
like indicative i know it's just a
cartoon character but is this
representative of
an example of a true example of
structural racism at least
as it relates to show business in this
country
and so i needed to look at my part so i
went and learned i read
and i talked to people i talked to a lot
of indian people i talked to a lot of
people who knew a lot about racism in
this country i took seminars i
read i kind of went back and forth and
back and forth and i know from program
to keep my mouth
shut until i have some idea of what the
hell i'm talking about
now i'm disappointed that uh he doesn't
provide more details
on the racist cartoon seminars are these
the same seminars that explain how pepe
le pew promotes rape culture
maybe they need to have a whole separate
event to cover that subject i don't know
in any case azaria's main concern seems
to be that he's contributed to spreading
the stereotype about indian people
owning convenience stores
and he talks about that in the interview
what he doesn't understand is that
such a stereotype would exist even
without the simpsons
they didn't create it they simply
remarked on it they noticed it
why because lots of indian people own
convenience stores so what
why is that an insult why is it a
problem to acknowledge that
how is it even a negative stereotype
that's a tough line of work it takes
intelligence and competence to be
successful
especially when you have these scumbags
running in and burning it down
the real stereotype here is that indian
people came to this country
and immediately became entrepreneurs oh
the horror how offensive
how offensive to accuse them of being
industrious
now admittedly the indian woman on the
show mona explains later in the show
that
the stereotype is only part of the
problem the other problem is
representation so she says that
if there was an indian person in every
show then apu
may not have been as much of a problem
but as it happens indian people don't
appear very often on american television
and and she attributes that of course to
racism but you know what i attribute
that to
most indian people don't become actors
because
they don't want to be actors many become
business owners
doctors engineers is that a problem
she's worried about representation in
hollywood and by the way indian people
have their own hollywood too and it
makes billions of dollars
a year but her concern is representation
on american sitcoms and stuff like that
what she doesn't explain is where we
should siphon
from in order to get these indian actors
right i mean if you want a bunch more
indian actors then you need more indian
people to become actors
uh we we need a lot of indian people who
are doing other things right now to
become
actors in order to get the
representation that she wants
so should we pull some of those indians
those indian surgeons out of their jobs
grab some of those indian scientists and
tech people
two of my best friends growing up were
indian both both now extremely
successful in their careers married you
know living the american dream
should i recruit them to become voice
actors on cartoon shows instead
by the way notice how mona is worried
about representation in hollywood
but she isn't worried about the lack of
indian representation among say
i don't know garbage collectors that's
the funny thing about the people who
scream
about representation the representation
demands that they make are
very specific and quite arbitrary and
based on their own
personal subjective priorities the
feminists too
they you never ever hear them complain
about the lack of female garbage
collectors and roofers and by the way
i've like never seen a female garbage
collector or roofer
no one ever complains about that why
because the people doing the complaining
don't think that those jobs are
important
or worthy they think it's much more
important to be on on tv
i don't think that they do
be all that as it may hank azaria is
still racked with guilt
indeed he says in the interview that he
wants to apologize to
every indian person individually he
actually says that
and you better get to it there are about
1.3 billion of them last i counted
so he's got his work cut out for him and
you know maybe this would be a good way
for him to spend the rest of his life he
can fly to india
and uh you know walk through the towns
and countrysides apologizing to each
indian person for voicing a cartoon
character
he can especially i think he should
start actually by going into the slums
in the cities
um find people in squalid impoverished
destitute conditions starving dying
in need of basic human necessities and
and you know he can go up to someone
like that he can lean down to them and
say
i am so so sorry
for that cartoon character and they can
look up at him and in their
eyes he will perhaps see himself for the
utterly ridiculous person that he is
and with any luck they'll look back at
him and say
among other things you're canceled
because he is today anyway and we'll
leave it there
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. squish
governor asa hutchinson takes
breitbart's maxim that politics is
downstream of culture to an absurd
extreme
major corporations collude to undermine
election integrity
and a new shooting sparks more riots
check it out on the michael knowles show